hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of this year's data
steel Masters Edition it is Magnus
Carlsen vs pragnananda and it is uh
quite the game it's it's incredibly
complicated and Incredibly enjoyable to
watch uh Magnus uh he had those two
losses in the middle of the tournament
but now he uh very much bounced back he
even won three games after those two
losses and Prague out of his four last
games he lost three games and only got
one draw and uh what's what's uh what's
the price for that playing uh Magnus
Carlsen with black uh but that's uh what
you have to do if you want to play Chess
at the absolute top level uh so let's
see how the game went it's absolutely a
crazy one so Magnus opens with Knight to
F3 he goes for the ready opening uh
sorry about that
uh we have Knight to F6 by Prague C for
C5 going for the symmetrical English
Knight to C3 Knight to C6 the Four
Knights of the English we have E3 E6 D4
and now D5 continuing in the uh
symmetrical symmetrical fashion uh we
have A3 and now D Cactus and C4
transposing into the semitage with
Bishop captures and now Pawn to A6 with
Queen back to D3 sorry Bishop to D3 uh
and this is already a very very
interesting attempt to buy Magnus there
are um and not a lot of games with this
we usually hear everyone just castles or
sometimes you play D captures on C5 but
Bishop to D3 is incredibly rare here so
C captures and D four by Prague E
Capture Sun D4 and now uh there are some
games where Bishop to E7 was played but
here we have Pawn to G6 and it is now as
of move 9 uh that we have a completely
new game if you're wondering about the
pawn here of course you cannot grab this
if you if Queen captures Bishop to B5
check and you bonded a queen in case
some of you were wondering about that so
upon the G6 a completely new game and
now Bishop to G5 with Bishop to G7 and
now Bishop to E4 again
uh one might expect Knights the E4 here
but Bishop to E4 uh and now Knight the
E7 and this is very very uh precise play
by Prague the problem is if you Castle
here which can be played uh the the the
the issue is Bishop capture spawn
captures and not Knight to E4 and it's
very difficult to get rid of this pin
you do have this bishop Queen to E5
check but now after Pawn to B4 and queen
to F5 uh let's say a trade happens
captures captures captures captures now
White Castles and this is what Magnus
had in mind uh he has a somewhat better
Pawn structure he would fight against
frogs the ANC isolated pawns uh
hopefully win one of them and then maybe
have a two to one advantage on the queen
side so it's not much but it's
definitely something to go on so Prague
wants to avoid this uh he plays Knight
to the E7 now preparing to re-maneuver
the Knight to D5 now Bishop captures and
C6 is no longer an option and his Pawn
structure will remain intact uh Ponte H4
by Magnus we have font H6 challenging
the bishop Bishop characters Bishop
captures and now Queen to D2 putting
pressure on the pawn so you can't really
Castle here and now the the way to stop
this is uh Pawn to H5 this is a very
clean or even prepared with Bishop to G7
but Prague was a knight to D5 right away
and now Magnus goes for it Ponte H5 and
okay G5 and now Knight to E5 and here uh
Bishop to G7 now just going back with
the bishop while you could capture here
if Knight captures of course not B
captures to allow a queen trade here but
rather Queen captures and now uh black
didn't really achieve anything with that
trade so instead Bishop to G7 by Prague
and here we have Bishop captures and D5
again Knight captures on D5 does seem to
be uh the way to go as it keeps the the
light Square Bishop alive on this
beautiful diagonal for some reason
Magnus doesn't like it and he decides to
give up the light score Bishop he plays
Bishop captures on D5 he captures on D5
and now uh he castles with Bishop to E6
by Prague and now just Rook a to E1 we
have castles and now Rook to E3 again uh
you could play F4 right away and try to
bust open the position but Magnus first
wants to get the Rook to G3 and then he
will have his Rooks nicely placed on the
G and F file both so here Bishop to F5
by prog probably with some ideas of
maybe
getting to that uh E4 square or even
maybe if it Rook to G3 what was kind of
the plan uh even play Bishop captures on
E5 and now the bishop controls the D3
Square for example D captures D4 and now
if you move the Knight even Pawn the D3
and the the pawn here is nicely
protected so probably something like
that but instead Magnus plays Queen to
D1 and now we have a rook to E8 and here
uh everyone was tweeting about it
everyone was screaming that Magnus is
now winning and that he will now win the
game as Knight captures and F7 upper
opportunity presented itself but Magnus
actually declines this it's it's a fine
idea but probably he thought that Prague
would have enough drawing chances the
problem with this is of course you
cannot capture with King captures
because of Rook to F3 but what you can
play is Queen to D7 and now the Knight
just has to go back Knight E5 now Rook
captures an E5 and now if D captures
then you just Advance the pawn to D4 so
Rook captures you give back Bishop
captures Decap address now D4 attack the
Knight Knight the E2 and now let's say
Rook to E8 or Rook to d8 uh you defend
your Pawn even better and uh
well it's a very very tricky position uh
white white is better the engine says
white is better because Black's king of
course is uh so uh so open it's very
easy to attack the the black king but
this past D Pawn is just so so nasty
once it comes to D3 it's defended by
everything and you just don't like this
but okay let's say ig3 Bishop to H7 you
can deliver a nice check here Queen to
B3 with check king or King will or you
will offer a queen trade now Queen B6
and it seems like
um uh White is making some progress but
still just D3 this is so annoying and
it's it's incredibly difficult to to
find moves here for white like Queen to
F6 is the engine's uh top move uh but it
doesn't really do all that much so uh
for a human it would be it would be
difficult to go into this voluntarily so
that's why not Knight captures an F7
Magnus just doubles up on the file Rook
fd1 Bishop back the E6 now proc stops
this idea and now Knight to A4 the
Knight now wants to come to the C5
Square so Pawn to B6 and now Rook the B3
also Queen to B3 a possibility Magnus um
decides to go for it with the rook and
now Queen to C7 and the situation on the
clock is 40 minutes for Magnus 20
minutes for Prague very important to
keep this in mind as we advance further
into the game here Magnus plays Knight
captures on B6 again uh Rook character
some B6 is also very much possible and
the idea being that now blacks only a
good maneuver is Bishop to D7 attacks
the Knight and puts pressure on the E
file and after Knight cat person D7 you
force a trade here captures captures now
Queen captures on D7 and probably why
Magnus didn't play this he uh probably
didn't look
as far as he should have maybe uh to
spot Queen to D1 here regarding the
Knight ended the pawn on H5 because if
you go for the for as your your knight
here is hanging if you go for Knights to
see five ninjas Queen to G4 and your H5
Pawn I will fall uh but yeah Queen to D1
here defends the Knight keeps an eye on
the pawn here and it's a very nice
position but still nothing nothing very
concrete at some point you will move the
Knight you will start pushing your your
pawns your create a pass pawn and that
is the way you will try to win this game
but he has a different idea Magnus plays
Knight captures on V6 attacks The Rook
Rook 8 to B8 and now Knight back to A4
here Prague trades we have a rook
captures Queen captures and Bishop
captures on E5 now that Knight an E5 is
a monster so
uh of course you want to get rid of it
d-capters on E5 and now Queen to A5
putting pressure on The Rook here so
Queen back to D1 and now Bishop to G4 a
very nice move by Prague trying to give
up the uh the bishop here and what's the
idea behind Bishop to G4 of course uh
just uh Queen captures Rook uh on E1 uh
so F3 uh defending with Bishop back to
D7 now attacking the Knight Knight the
C3 and now Queen to C5 with check and
now Magnus has to decide uh is the king
better placed on H1 or an H2 and uh
pretty much whatever whatever you play
uh will will result in the same thing so
Magnus goes King to H2 and now uh we
have this beautiful beautiful forcing
line Ponte D4 and now uh pretty much the
only good move for Magnus Rook to E4 and
now he's saying that I'm I'm gonna
capture the pawn on D4 and if you
capture on C3 then Queen captures bishop
and D7 and there's is not all that much
to consider here one other possibility
is Rook captures an E5 but then just
Queen captures on D4 and now if Queen
captures you're gonna play Rook captures
on D4 and now let's say Bishop T6 King
to G3 and so on the at the end game uh
starts with with white being uh with
white being better white is up a pawn
and should have some chances to push for
a win here but here we have D capitals
and C3 and now look at this queen
captures on D7 attacks The Rook here uh
23 minutes for Magnus seven minutes for
Prague only and this is move 34 you
still need to make six moves to reach
time control
uh proc has two options uh one of them
is Rook captures on E5 which makes sense
your Rook is attacked and the pawn here
is hanging but he didn't play this I
will just show you what happens if Rook
captures for example B4 you chase away
the queen queen to D5 you offer a queen
trade captures captures and now you go
after the the fast Pawn black has to
play Rook D3 bit of a passive move but
okay now A4 B5 and so on uh White will
be pushing here most likely uh very very
hard to say with perfect play of course
it's a draw as most uh most positions
are but proc doesn't go for that proc
plays Pawn to C2 he gives up The Rook
with check and here you have to play
Everything Everything absolutely
precisely in order not to get checkmated
so Queen captures 98 with Chuck King the
G7 and now uh Magnus has two options uh
C1 is being threatened here Prague will
get another queen into the game and if
he plays Rook the E1 is just a very
quick draw and let me show you quick
Rook to E1 now Queen to F2 attacks the
rook and after Rook to C1 Queen to H4
with check now you can't play
um uh well you can play for example King
to G1 but now Queen to D4 check and now
you cannot go back if King King to H2
then Queen F4 check will pick up lubric
and C1 so you're gonna have to play King
to H1 but now Queen captures on B2 and
that there's nothing better than the
capture on C2 for example Rook captures
Queen captures and now after King the H2
Queen to C4 and uh black will always
have sufficient compensation here for
the lack of material
uh the lack of material being the the
extra Pawn that white has uh but there
there will be no way for for white to
push this so instead we have pawned the
B4 attacks the queen and this allows
proc to keep an eye on the E1 square but
this is where the game takes uh well
just goes to a completely new level
Queen to C3 and now the problem is if
Magnus could play E6 it'd be great but
Prague now has Queen to C7 check and
everything is defended the F7 Pawn is
defended and even after G3 and C1 Queen
e captures an F7 now going for f8 Queen
uh there's Queen captures on F7 this is
the only good move and now after Rook to
E7 sort of winning back some material
Queen to C2 check ensures a Perpetual
King H3 Queen to F5 with Chair King H2
and now Queen the city with check uh
black will have a nice draw here so
instead Magnus goes Pawn to F4 and uh I
mean what is this C1 Queen Magnus goes
Pawn to F5 now prank has two queens but
it's a bit difficult to start checking
that white king so he goes Queen to c7s
he stops the advancement of the E Pawn
but now Pawn to F6 check by Magnus King
to H7 and queen to f8 Magnus is now
threatening Checkmate and there is only
one move to stop Checkmate and I'm sure
you can see it as uh well it's literally
the only one so you you cannot miss it
you have to give back material Queen
captures an E5 with check
this removes The Rook from the defense
of the F4 square and then Queen F4 check
will pick up the F6 Pawn as well so Rook
captures on E5 we have Queen to F4 with
check and now not G3 if G3 then you just
allow black a very quick Perpetual with
Queen to F2 so instead we have King to
G1 and now Queen to C1 you cannot
capture The Rook if you capture The Rook
is just going to be Checkmate so here
Prague goes for another check King F2
and now Queen to F4 with check very
important Prague wants to win The Rook
with check and then the F6 Pawn as well
and if Magnus wants to go back okay we
have a Perpetual if Magnus wants to
continue the game he has to give back
the rook and the F6 pawn and he does
Magnus wants to continue King to E2
Queen captures an E5 check King to D3
now Queen captures an F6 and queen to E8
now and all of a sudden we have this uh
Queen and pawn end game uh where white
has four pawns black has four pawns so
it's equal material and everything that
happened so far doesn't really matter
now it's a completely new game and uh
you just have to play it right from the
start so here Queen to F1 with check
magnus's plan of course is to bring the
king somehow all the way at A5 and the
win the A6 spawn and then start pushing
those pawns and Prague has to somehow
try to eliminate at least one of these
pawns uh hopefully with check and then
start advancing his own pawns while
avoiding tracks so as you might imagine
with perfect play this should be a draw
but there is a lot more to play for here
so King D4 King to G7 now defending F7
so now the black queen can move from the
f-file queen to E5 with checking to G8
and queen to B8 with check with King G7
and now Queen to G3 it will be easier to
avoid all the checks uh and you are
defending most of your weaknesses here
so Queen to D1 check King to C5 and now
Queen captures on H5 but now Queen to E5
with checking to G8 and Ponte A4 for so
Magnus gives a gives one Pawn gives up
one Pawn at the start advancing on the
queen side and create a pass pawn and
now uh we have Queen to D1 uh and uh
Magnus goes Pawn to A5 you could play
Pawn to B5 uh it's actually a very
interesting idea uh but uh black will
not capture the A4 Pawn that would be
bad for black black will just trade and
now for example Queen to G1 with check
and if Queen to D4 Queen captures and G2
and Magnus would be uh uh having this
beautiful pass Pawn already on B6 for
example G4 Queen to D5 offering the
queen trade but black will be able to
defend this there are so many checks you
can give here and the black is also up
to pawn so Magnus doesn't like this uh
so instead he plays Ponta uh after Queen
to D1 he plays Pawn to A5 and now Queen
to G1 with check we have Queen to D4
Queen captures and G2 and now Pawn to B5
hoping uh that uh frog will capture so
he can start advancing the a pawn but
Prague just starts advancing his own
past Pawn so Pawn to G4 B captures an A6
and now Pawn to G3 here we have uh 30
minutes for Magnus and 10 minutes again
for prog this is already move 57 Ponte
A7 Magnus very close to queening but
prox Queen defends that A8 Square so
Queen to A8 and now preparing to advance
the pawn to G2 now King to D6 with Pawn
to G2 and King to E5
uh Queen back to F3 now comes Queen to
d8 with check King to H7 and now A8
Queen bring you a queen into the game
and uh while Prague could just trade
here he plays Queen to C3 with check
first Magnus blocks we have characters
captures and now G1 uh with check a G1
Queen with check King to D3 Queen to D1
with check and now with the board
um uh you know there are no more secrets
on the board King the E3 Queen T1
checking to D3 Queen to D1 check and it
was in this position and move 67 that
Magnuson Prague agreed to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here so
truly a wild game played brilliantly by
both of them and Magnus maybe could have
um uh played a few better moves but
those are all I mean pretty much engine
lines uh if you spotted all that you
would not be playing against humans
pretty much uh so yeah really wild game
uh a lot of Queens on the board you know
after all of that Madness then you had
have to settle down in the this you know
just accepted it now you have to play a
queen and opponent game and probably
just played everything uh up to
Perfection uh in the end he was able to
save the game uh that's pretty much all
there is uh we're gonna check at least
one more game from the penultimate round
and we're gonna see what this means for
the standings uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank John Noonan Russell L Scott Lassie
maltzer a friend's book called and
ravishing reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Tata steel Masters and Challengers
Edition uh until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day